new york mayor bill de blasio announces
life passports for the vaccinated and
bans for everyone else and
new york attorney general leticia james
blows up new york governor andrew cuomo
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
for a moment and plenty of news there is
first let me remind you that there are a
lot of people who are interested
in your internet activity that may
include your vpn
provider okay the fact is that a lot of
the people who say they're providing
with a free vpn are actually
aggregating your data they're selling
your data not so with expressvpn
i can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is the best vpn on the market
and here is why
number one expressvpn unlike those other
vpns will not log
your data also they're really fast i've
tried lots of vpns in the past many will
slow your connection down make your
device sluggish
i've been using expressvpn for a long
time my internet speeds are blazing fast
even when i connect to servers thousands
of miles away
i can still stream hd quality videos
with zero lag
the final thing that really sets
expressvpn apart from the other vpns is
how easy it is to use
unlike other vpns you don't have to
input or program anything just fire up
the app you click one button
and now you are connected so protect
yourself with the vpn i use and trust it
use my link expressvpn.com today get an
extra three months free
on a one year package that's
expressvpn.com visit expressvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so
mayor bill de blasio has now announced
the time
has come vaccine passports now you knew
it's coming
you know it's only a matter of time
before some blue city mayor decided
we need to check your papers your papers
we need to check your papers it's very
important that we know whether you're
vaccinated
or not and no that's not a nazi thing
okay there are lots of other nations
that have been doing it it's a bad idea
everywhere it is and it is violative of
basic human liberty number one it's
going to be very difficult to check
everybody's
vaccine passports because frankly a lot
of people who got the vaccine
didn't receive a vaccine card some
people's vaccine cards like mine
got dispelled some people didn't bother
to get a vaccine cards or they got rid
of the first vaccine somewhere in like
new york and then they went for the
second shot somewhere in massachusetts
it's gonna be very difficult to actually
enforce
all of this you've seen this at
lollapalooza so all palooza in chicago
you're all supposed to show your vaccine
card what that really amounts to when
you watch the video
is people holding up a paper a piece of
paper and walking through a line with
hundreds of people
it's it's like tsa except without any
metal detectors meaning it is completely
theater right it's all for show and all
of this
in order to what presumably protect the
vaccinated like it doesn't make any sort
of logical sense the vaccinated
themselves are not at grave risk of
hospitalization or death
from covid the unvaccinated if you wish
to lower the curve
the unvaccinated should be hanging out
with the vaccinated not in their own
special spaces so i guess the logic here
is that if you're vaccinated you're one
of the special people if you're
unvaccinated you're one of the unspecial
people and if we punish you for being
unvaccinated then sooner or later you'll
get bored with it
and you will go and get yourself
vaccinated well
there's an alternative possibility which
is that you won't right which is that
you'll be so off put
you'll be so alienated that you just
won't get the vaccine and instead you'll
hang out with the other unvaccinated in
restaurants outside of new york city
and you will infect each other and you
will actually end up with a higher rate
of people passing the virus to one
another now the reason i say this is
because
new york is not the first place to have
tried this let's start with this here's
bill de blasio actually announcing
this kind of dumbassical policy the key
to nyc pass will be a first
in the nation approach it will require
vaccination for workers and customers
in indoor dining in indoor fitness
facilities
indoor entertainment facilities this is
going to be a requirement
the only way to patronize these
establishments
indoors will be if you're vaccinated at
least one dose
all right now here is the thing
a couple problems with this and first
the logical which we've mentioned
then there's the intersectional problem
with this so for example
what exactly is going to happen in new
york city when black people can't go
to like any of the places because right
now bill de blasio is arguing
that unless you have a covet vaccine or
proof of a covered vaccine
then you can't go to an indoor eatery a
gym
or an entertainment center de blasio
says the city is going to start finding
businesses
first of all this should not be a
governmental thing if you're a private
business and you only want to allow the
vaccinated
in because a bunch of paranoid people in
your company or whatever
that's your business if the city is
cramming this down on you they better
have
pretty good public health reason they
really don't de blasio says the city is
going to start finding and inspecting
businesses for compliance in
mid-september
all affected customers and workers can
either provide their vaccination cards
or upload their proof of vaccination
to the excelsior pass application and
obviously if new york city knows one
thing
it is how to do public
sort of service they're really really
good at handling
complex id based transactions sort of
like how it took them
multiple weeks to figure out who the
actual new mayor of new york is going to
be
after screwing up the original vo totals
they're going to be great they're g
there'd be no bugs there's going to be
no no hiccups in the pro it's going to
be
just absolutely smooth this by the way
came
a day after de blasio mandated
vaccinations for all of the city's new
hires
requiring them to provide proof of
vaccination by their first day of work
without the option to get tested
regularly instead he issued similar
mandates for city employees and
healthcare workers
in july according to cnbc according to
de blasio about 11 000 people have
picked up a hundred bucks in order to
get their vaccinations so far
uh that started on july 30th and uh and
so
you know basically we now have a
two-tier system in new york you're a
citizen if you're vaccinated you're an
uncitizen if not well there's going to
be a major intersectional problem for
bill de blasio here
it is lurking in the stats so here
are the stats coveted vaccine data
biracial group
in new york city he has himself
a bit of a problem with the
intersectional coalition
the percent of asians were fully
vaccinated
in new york city and remember you need
to be fully vaccinated one vaccine is
enough
fully vaccinated in order to get the
vaccine passport the percentage of
asians were fully vaccinated in new york
city
71 percent the number the percentage of
native americans and alaska natives
who have been vaccinated fully 67 the
percentage of white people
who've been fully vaccinated is 45
and the percentage of black people in
new york city who have been fully
vaccinated
is 31 7 out of every 10 black people in
new york city has not been fully
vaccinated
so how do you think this is going to
play out for bill de blasio and his
democrats
how do you think this is going to play
out when restaurants are overtly turning
away a disproportionate number of black
people
now i have been told by ibram kendy and
robin deangelo
that any inequality in society is proof
of systemic inequity
and so obviously bill de blasio is a
racist
i mean just as testing just as sat
testing is racist
just as we have learned that picking up
people for crimes
is racist even if they committed the
crime if a disproportionate number of
those people are black that's racist
a disproportionate number of people are
now not going to be able to go to the
new york city bodega
because they're not vaccinated and those
people will happen to be black
disproportionately
and it's going to be fun to watch as new
york eats itself
in the battle between the the hyper
active and super afraid
upper crust white liberals in new york
and the black population which is
overwhelmingly not vast
in new york it's going to be fun to
watch the robin d'angelo half of the
white liberal population go to war
with itself am i racist i don't know if
i'm racist i mean i really want people
to get vaccinated right but the blacks
aren't getting vaccinated what do we do
i don't know
oh i i hate me i watch
these sort of bizarre schizophrenia of
the new york upper crust
left is going to come out in a rabid
rabbit then of course they'll just blame
trump then they'll just say it's the
american system the real reason black
americans aren't getting vaccinated
is because america writ large is racist
that's always the solution now
let's go to the question of whether
these vaccine passports actually work
so here's the thing we have some
evidence that the answer is not so much
okay back in january
israel launched a covet immunity
passport according to cnbc
this january of this year israel has
been lauded for deploying what is
currently the fastest coven 19
vaccination campaign in the world
less than a month after receiving its
first shipments of the of the pfizer
bio and tech jab the country of 9
million has vaccinated about 20
of its population more than 72 percent
of people over the age of 60 had already
gotten
their first dose essentially they are
now
what releasing what they call this again
back in january what was called
the green booklet the green booklet
would be given to people who have
received
two doses of the vaccine the booklet
would offer vaccinated individuals
significant freedom from cover 19 safety
restrictions people holding it would no
longer have to go into isolation after
coming in contact with an infected
person
or going to isolation after traveling
internationally they would no longer
have to be tested before entering
certain touristy areas
known as green islands they would still
have to be wearing a mask in public and
maintaining social distancing
right this the vaccinated okay so they
were still pretty strict in israel
for the vaccinated since january so what
has the result of all of that been
quote times of israel today daily
coveted cases surge past
3 800. ministers to mull and new
restrictions the high-level coronavirus
cabinet was set to convene tuesday to
approve new restrictions
as the daily covet-19 caseload surpassed
3 000
for the first time since march according
to the health ministry 3 800 new cases
were diagnosed on monday with 3.78
of tests returning positive the number
of serious cases stood at 221
of whom 46 were on ventilators
so the so-called green pass by the way
was reinstated by the government on
thursday with a with entry to events of
more than 100 people both indoors and
outdoors
allowed only to those who are vaccinated
recovered or who present a negative cova
test
children under the age of 12 were
largely exempt from the system
so they kind of went in with the green
passport then they went out with the
green passport and here's the thing
it really has done very little okay the
green passports
are not really accomplishing what they
seek to accomplish in fact i've not seen
these vaccine passports anywhere
accomplish what they seek to accomplish
in terms of either forcing all of the
unvaccinated to get vaccinated
or in terms of lowering the rate of
infection
from covet 19. and in fact things are
going very poorly in france so france
also has a vaccine passport system and
it's resulting in
mass protests across france there's an
entire piece in the new york times
today from a person named pauline bach
who's a french journalist she says
at a time of the year when the french
are traditionally divided between those
who go on holiday in july and those who
go on august the past few weeks have
seen hundreds of thousands of people
coming together with a single rallying
cry
liberte these protesters are united
against france's new system of vaccine
passes which was announced with much
fanfare by the government on july 12
and is gradually coming into effect the
measures intended to lift the
vaccination rate
as the delta variant courses around the
country make proof of vaccination or a
negative covet test mandatory to get
into cultural venues bars and
restaurants
by september all care workers will need
such a pass to retain their job
and workers on a permanent contract may
be suspended without pay
until they can provide one though to
some extent it's successful in its
primary aim
in the weeks since this was announced
6.5 million people have been vaccinated
taking the level to 47 about the same
proportion as in the us
the move however has rebounded badly
against the government
many people unhappy at the act of
coercion are taking to the streets in a
collective display of defiance
potentially coalescing into a
substantial protest movement that could
mar
president emmanuel macron's re-election
efforts next year
and france's experience is a cautionary
tale so you have
tons and tons and tons of people who
have been out protesting against this
not because tons of french people are
vex deniers
only about 16 percent of french
residents say they intend not to be
vaccinated and by the time the macron
announced the rollout of vaccine passes
over half of the french population had
gotten at least one dose
their concerns instead were about
freedom and rights
and exactly how this was going to take
place according again to this columnist
in the new york times
protesters fear that the passes will
allow for wide-ranging state
surveillance
potentially targeting the most
vulnerable and even suppressing dissent
there's no guarantee they warn that the
system will be retired once the
once the virus is defeated ironically
the only trade exempt from mandatory
vaccination the cops will be the ones to
make sure everyone else
obeys the policy is ripe for
authoritarian misuse again this is not
coming
from the american right wing this is
coming from the french
okay so so the the idea of a vaccine
passport in new york city they tried it
in israel
it's been pretty unsuccessful they tried
it in france it's been
so far not supremely successful and a
driver
of mass unrest and yet people keep
rushing forward with all this
again based on what based on what like
i'm just wondering
why is this panic happening right now if
you look at new york city
the number of cova deaths in new york
city right now
day on day average five in new york city
five again new york city population
right now is approximately 8.4
million there are a day a day down day
average of five deaths per day
in new york city five out of 8.5 million
and they're talking about vaccine
passports for everyone by the way if you
look at the number of cases the number
of cases has been rising
their seven-day average is about 1200
cases
okay that that's a somewhat big number
when they were at their sort of highest
numbers back in january
they were getting something like 6 000
sometimes 7 000 cases
a day right now they're like 1200 cases
a day so they're like one-fifth of that
but again the vaccines are available to
everyone
so leave everybody alone but they're not
going to leave everybody alone in fact
it's going to get even worse
the national institute of health
director francis collins again i don't
know where they get these folks
but they're just they're terrible at
this nih director francis collins is now
telling
parents that they should wear masks in
their own homes to protect
their kids from covid despite the fact
that there is no evidence at this point
of increased deadliness from the delta
variant in kids
according by the way to people who work
for the biden administration
collins is saying stuff like this it's
clear that the variance is capable of
causing serious injury
in children you've heard stories coming
out of louisiana pediatric icus where
there are kids as young as a few months
old
who are sick from this that's rare but
anyone that tried to tell you you don't
have to worry about it if you're a young
healthy person there's a lot of counter
examples all around
no that's anecdotal you can't do that
okay if you're if your
basic pitch is you should worry about
your kids because here's some anecdotal
data of kids getting super
super ill from covid no stats just
anecdotal data
you are arguing in the exact same
preserve as people who are like i'm not
giving my kid a vaccine
because i heard about this one kid who
had an adverse effect from the vaccine
anecdotal data means zero it means
nothing
zero things does it mean in terms of
your personal risk assessment
because they're anecdotes of lots of bad
stuff happening on earth all the time
this is why again it sounds like this is
very much about control here's francis
collins pushing this thing yesterday
you have heard those stories coming out
of louisiana pediatric
icu's where there are kids as young as a
few months old who are sick from this
that is rare certainly younger people
are less likely to fall ill
but anybody who tries to tell you ah you
don't have to worry about it if you're a
young healthy person
there's many counter examples all around
us now
so yeah you do need to think about it
and that's the reason why the
recommendations
are for kids under 12 that they avoid
being in places where they might get
infected which means recommendations
of mask wearing in schools and that at
home are parents
of unvaccinated kids at home at home i'm
no are you insane when you mean parents
of unvaccinated kids
let's just be straight about this he
means every parent you cannot
legally give a vaccine to a child under
12 in the united states
he means every single parent in the
united states
should be wearing a mask in their home
with their kids
are you out of your damned my answer is
yes they're out of their damn minds
they're out of their damn minds and
here's the thing
once again human beings are not capable
of controlling everything that happens
we have human beings an unbelievable
ability to adapt we created one of the
great scientific creations of all time
in this vaccine it's
unbelievable it's it's miraculous it's
unbelievable
unbelievably miraculous but we can't
control everything because we can't
control everything
people on the left think we can as
they're just going to keep doubling down
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that you don't
really want to go to the auto parts
store i know you woke up this morning
you're thinking i'd love to go to the
auto parts store
wrong no one thinks that way instead why
not skip the auto parts store where
you'll wait in line
answer a bunch of questions and then the
person behind the counter will be like
yeah dude i have to order it online wait
three weeks i'll up charge
or just use the interwebs rockauto.com
they always offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear
like airlines do why spend up to twice
as much for the same parts they're a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose
the brands specifications and prices you
prefer head on over to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car
or truck right shapiro in their how did
you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you again rockauto.com
family business american business go to
rockotter.com shop for the auto and body
parts you need from hundreds of
manufacturers get the best possible
price
write shapiro and then how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you okay so
again the reason that i point out that
maybe human beings aren't in control of
this is because human beings obviously
are not in control of this
bangladesh is seeing a massive spike
right now according to the new york
times
with bangladesh under a nationwide
lockdown to fight a third wave of covid
hospitals in the capital dhaka are
reaching capacity demand for oxygen is
exceeding supply
obviously governor ronda sanchez is at
fault here on sunday the government
granted an exemption allowing the count
the country's critical ready-made
garments industry to keep operating
promising fears among experts the health
crisis could worsen but it's not just
bangladesh
it's also back in china where they lied
by the way china says
that this entire time they've lost like
5 000 people they're just unbelievable
liars just unbelievable liars right now
wuhan is planning to test all
11 million residents for covid now i was
told by the health experts china just
did an amazing job locking this stuff
down
nope the city had not recorded in any
local cases since may of last year
after a harsh two and a half month
lockdown helped eradicate the virus
their butt
city officials say they had detected
three symptomatic local cases in the
previous 24 hours
five asymptomatic cases they're testing
all 11 million people i don't
think that they detected three cases and
they're testing 11 million people i
think they have a lot of cases
japan is starting to see a surge as well
according to the new york times as japan
strains to contain its
galloping coronavirus outbreak and to
keep an olympic bubble from bursting in
the final days of the games the
government is now trying a new tactic
public shaming
on monday japan's health ministry
released the names of three people who
broke
over 19 rules after returning from
overseas apparently this was two
japanese nationals in their 20s who just
came back from south korea a third who
came from hawaii
apparently they had acted to avoid
contact with the authorities they're
trying to shame the hell out of people
because infections over there are rising
on tuesday officials said they had
recorded
more than 8 300 daily cases nationwide
the the it's starting to uh come down
the other side of the curve it looks
like in japan a little bit
but here's the bottom line this sort of
stuff is happening nearly everywhere
and ronda sanchez came out in florida
because of course rhonda sanchez is
always the the
bad guy in all of this according to the
left he came out
and he said i don't think we've reached
the peak yet but he said hospitals are
not overwhelmed yet
they are open for non-coveted business
which by the way is still true
he said we're not shutting down we're
going to have schools open we're
protecting every floridian's job in this
state these interventions have failed
time and again in this pandemic they
have not
stopped the spread correct and then
he said that um you know when when
people when reporters were like what
about kids with coca-19
he said the reporter was blaming kids
for not wearing masks and getting sick
and called the question deplorable which
it is
and then he said listen what i did is i
focused on protecting
the seniors and i accomplished he's
correct about all of that the media
however have decided that rhonda sanses
is the worst so
it is now worthwhile to explore why
there is a surge in florida
okay here's the thing the answer is
really really obvious there's a surge in
florida right now because it's
really hot outside it's hot and
simultaneously rainy okay i'm a new
immigrant to florida and let me just
tell you florida is wonderful in the
summer it gets unbelievably hot
unbelievably humid
and it rains a lot in the afternoon and
what this means is that people go inside
where do you think covet is transmitted
it is transmitted inside
when there's lots of aerosolized spit
blowing all over the place from air
conditioning
and heating this is not a shock okay
here for example
is a chart cases by region in the united
states
look at this chart cases by region what
you see first of all is louisiana's
really spiking why
i wonder well could it be because
louisiana's in the south and it's really
damned hot outside
in louisiana right now and so people are
staying inside okay so
this chart from the new york times cuts
the united states into four regions
west midwest south and northeast you
will notice that this virus is seasonal
depending on the weather so right now
the south leads the way in terms of case
count then the west because it's really
hot in the south and in the west
then the midwest where it's cooler and
then finally the northeast where it is
coolest
now let's reverse back to say you know
like um january right when things were
really bad
if you look at january what you will see
is that the weather
dictates exactly how this goes right in
the in the middle of january in the
middle of the spike
what you see is that the west and the
south where there were fewer
people who had already you know had the
virus generally speaking than in the
northeast what you see is that northeast
spikes
and now the northeast is close to the
top of the pack along with the west and
the south
and you'll see that if you go back even
further than that if you go back to like
november december when the spike first
started
the midwest takes over why did the
midwest take over in late december
november
why could it be because it gets really
cold outside and so a lot of people
go to the inside oh so maybe it doesn't
have to do with policy
it has to do with the weather oh i mean
we knew this last year by the way we
knew this
so that that is not a shock at all at
all
all right so is all the all this the
predicate to
government passports and nearly
everything right because again the case
in favor of government passports for
vaccines at this point
is extremely weak statistically it's
extremely weak
on a logical level it's really weak
there there's no
real sort of end goal here that
justifies
the notion that if you're unvaccinated
now we're just going to bar you from
every business by the government i mean
that's kind of crazy and it's going to
result
in a massive anti-government backlash
okay well
you can see that this again is is part
and parcel of a broader sort of
authoritarian
move that that you can see in terms of
ideology there's a good piece today
from kristen tate over at the hill
called coming soon america's own
social credit system and here's what she
says she says the new domestic war on
terror kicked off by the ride on january
6th
has prompted several web giants to
unveil predecessors so it effectively
could become a soft social credit system
by the end of this decade
relying on an indirect hand from dc our
social bettors in corporate america will
attempt to force the most profound
changes our society has seen
during the internet era china's social
credit system is a combination of
government and business surveillance
that gives its citizens a score
that can restrict the ability of
individuals to take actions such as
purchasing plane tickets acquiring
property or taking loans
because of behaviors given the position
of several major american companies
a similar system may be coming here
sooner than you think here's the thing
if we can start basically telling people
whether they are allowed to engage in
business
based on whether they decide to get a
vaccine or not as an
individual adult human being you can
quickly see that the left which has
declared anything they don't like in
actual danger right this is part of the
broader sort of microaggression ideology
pushed by the left
it is not a far leap from we need
vaccine passports
because we have to protect ourselves
against the public health menace of the
unvaccinated to
we need social credit passports because
we need to protect ourselves against the
menace of people who disagree with us
if you think that's a long jump all you
have to do is look at college campuses
where they've already started
implementing this sort of language all
the time on the left
last week says says it's columnist for
the hill paypal announced a partnership
with the left-wing southern poverty law
center to investigate the role of white
supremacists
and propagators of anti-government
rhetoric subjective labels that
potentially could impact
a large number of groups or people using
their service facebook is taking similar
measures
recently introducing messages that ask
users to snitch on their potentially
extremist
friends which considering the platform's
bias seems mainly to target the
political right
at the same time facebook and microsoft
are working with several other web
giants and the un
on a database to block potential
extremist content
the actions of these major companies may
seem logical in an internet riddled with
scams and crime
no one's going to defend far-right
militias or white supremacist groups
using these platforms but
the same issue with government
censorship exists with corporate
censorship if there is a line who draws
it
and you've seen that this is sort of the
left's take more generally
on who ought to be part of the american
body politic
and who ought not to be and this is why
they're making such a big deal
out of january 6 six months after it
happened and even though the people who
are responsible
have been arrested and will end up going
to jail now the latest
sort of iteration of this particular
argument is an argument over
two dc police officers who were present
at the january 6th riot and have now
died by suicide according to the
metropolitan police department these are
the third and fourth officers to commit
suicide
mpd spokesperson chris kristen metzger
told cnn monday
officer gunther hashida an 18-year
veteran on the force was found dead at
his residence on thursday
which of course is tragic and terrible
hashida was assigned to the emergency
response team
within the special operations division
was dispatched to the capitol on
january 6th only hours later the mpd
confirmed another suicide had taken
place that of course didn't happen the
same day
it had happened in mid-july we don't
have
any information as to whether these
officers committed suicide because of
january 6 or whether there's a
connection
to january 6th and realistically
speaking unfortunately
police officers are disproportionately
likely to commit suicide
that 176 police officers died by suicide
in 2020 alone
we don't know the departmental breakdown
on those numbers you'd assume basically
the bigger the police department the
more police officers probably committed
suicide she would assume more
police officers commit suicide in just
on an absolute raw number level in new
york
la chicago dc then elsewhere
but this is being used as a as an excuse
to basically say that all republicans
are now responsible
for police officers committing suicide
chris cuomo said just that he said
republicans are to blame for these
suicides does he have information we
don't who knows
may he rest in peace we need to see his
life and death for what it is
noah's name hashida same for capital
officer howard liebengood
and dc metro officer jeffrey smith why
all three died by suicide after the
january 6th attack
hashida's death last week was announced
today
they had 45 years of experience among
them yet
the same people who claimed blue lives
matter
mocked laughed disparaged
the wounds inflicted on these men wounds
of that day are going to go far beyond
the 140 officers beaten with flagpoles
stabbed with metal fence stakes
smashed over the head with fire
extinguishers and more
the survivors told you the extent
themselves last week okay all this is
all of this you know would would count
if we were talking about the police
officer who testified last week again
we don't even know why these police
officers committed suicide there are a
wide variety of reasons
unfortunately why people become suicidal
unless there's information that he has
that we don't we don't know that this
actually was connected
to january 6th and anyway which is sort
of important to point out also i've
noticed
that there have been no reports on any
of the suicides that have taken place
this year
in other police departments apparently
there have been 18 suicides
overall in the united states by police
officers were those connected to black
lives matter
who the hell knows right we don't know
in the same way that he doesn't know
that this was connected to january 6th
per se he's a lot of police officers
were put in pretty ugly situations
last year but the goal here is to blame
all republicans for this in fact the
former d.c police deputy
chief blamed republicans for these
police suicides as well
when you hear our elected officials
people that you should really look
up to start to try to spin a story of
something as serious as what took place
on january 6 and trying to make it into
something that never happened
or it was just like a regular tourist
event we all know that's not true the
same people saying that we're
barricading the doors and hiding in the
basement of the visitor center
at that particular point in time but to
hear them say that
is not only disrespectful it does create
additional trauma
this has become the latest talking point
and if you think again that the sort of
social credit system that's being
created now the power given to
government now
to basically allow you to attend
businesses or not attend businesses
based on the quote-unquote danger that
you pose to others
in defiance of the data by the way if
that can't be extended
to ideology i mean i i have doubts
i have doubts that the left will not
attempt to do something like that and i
find that highly
disquieting okay in just a second we're
going to be getting to
letitia james the attorney general of
the state of new york has now released
a devastating report on andrew cuomo's
unfortunate pension not for killing the
elderly right that doesn't matter
anymore the doj
the biden doj decided it was not worth
investigating andrew cuomo killing all
the old people in new york and then
covering it up
it was much worthier of investigation
that the man loves to grab ass
apparently
and uh yes that's really bad you know
it's worse killing a bunch of old people
and lying about it but
it is indeed bad that the new york
governor has a penchant for putting both
his hands in inappropriate places
apparently we'll get to that in just
one moment first you know as you get
older you can get tired okay let's be
real you got a lot going on in your life
career
family staying in shape life can get
stressful you start to slow down you're
not present when you want to be to
perform at your best physically and
mentally you can't let age
beat you this is where m drive can help
m drive is the daily supplement for
driven men who don't want to slow down
who refuse to be tired every day who
want to be the best at what they do
it's packed with clinically tested
ingredients that support healthy
testosterone levels
while helping you lose weight and stay
lean added vitamins and nutrients
reduce stress boost your drive so you
can perform at your best you can find
m drive today at walgreens and other
retailers or visit mdrive4men.com get 20
off your first order with promo code ben
they've got free shipping a 60-day
money-back guarantee so
you have nothing to lose m drive it is
not for everyone it's for
the driven mdrive4men.com promo code ben
again that's
m drive for men.com promo code
ben the reality is that unfortunately as
you get older you may lose that energy
level you need to get that energy level
up and the solution could be
mdriveformen.com for you
get 20 off your first order with promo
code ben free shipping 60-day money-back
guarantee so
you have nothing to lose go check them
out right now alrighty in just one
second we're gonna get to
new york attorney general leticia james
going after new york governor andrew
cuomo
a kind of sorta first you may have
noticed that this
authoritarian moment is upon us i have
an entire book called the authoritarian
moment it talks about the twisting of
science the perversion of our scientific
institutions
you may have noticed that your corporate
overlords are looking down
your the back of your neck they're
breathing down the back of your neck
they're trying to control what you say
what you think you've noticed to see
universities from the media the
authoritarian moment describes
how all of these institutions of power
have been hijacked and re-normalized by
a militant and aggressive left
and more importantly it explains how you
can fight back it is a must read if i do
say so myself
i'm biased go check it out the
authoritarian moment it is now available
at amazon barnes and noble or any other
major bookseller go get your copy right
now leave a five star review let others
know this book
is worth their time also if you would
love to know what it's like to be in the
presence of the always trending candace
owens you're in luck
you can now enter to win a free trip to
meet her and be part of her live studio
audience if you sign up now
as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 25 off your new membership
and
be automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip for two to the daily wear
studios and see candace live
not only will you be meeting candace
you'll be getting an inside look at her
studio and front row seats to watch her
destroy the left's insidious ideology on
her talk show candace
it's a good time on candace's set this
isn't an opportunity i would pass up
were iu so if you're in the mood for a
vacation with a side of leftist
takedowns go enter now to win two vip
tickets to canvas at dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 25
off also also we have so much to offer
you today it may seem
like a dream a utopian dream but you
could be lounging with
us your favorite hosts backstage it's
now within your reach
we are giving away a free trip for two
to come hang out with the daily wire
host backstage here at our national
studio you can meet all of us
tour the studios and offices get great
swag from our swag bag of merch watch us
debate on the show live so
if you're not a member yet head on over
to dailywire.com backstage enter a code
backstage or checkout for 25
off your membership get automatically
entered to win what i would call the
coolest
trip you might ever take you'll be
telling your children
grandchildren great grandchildren about
you're going to carve it on your
headstone that's how great this trip is
going to be
again head on over to dailywire.com
backstage with code backstage to get 25
off your membership and a chance to win
the ultimate backstage experience you're
listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
alrighty meanwhile andrew cuomo under
fire not for killing all the
elderly people in new york and then
covering it up but because the man
apparently cannot keep his hands off
other people's asses apparently this is
like the big thing over there
right now now you'll recall that the
current president of the united states
joe biden said in an interview back in
march
that if the allegations against andrew
cuomo were confirmed that he should
resign
and here's joe biden saying just that if
the investigation confirms the claims of
the women
should he resign yes i think he probably
ended up being prosecuted too
and well now it has been confirmed that
this is precisely what andrew cuomo
did according to attorney general
leticia james who herself
i will say has her eye on the
gubernatorial seat i mean it's pretty
obvious that leticia james wants to run
for governor
this is part of the problem with having
an ag with her eye on that top seed is
like
they get you in the crosshairs and it
can get real ugly real fast but
it's pretty obvious from i mean the
report on andrew cuomo's penchant
for ask rabbery is um 168 pages long
so that is a lot of buttocks grabbed
that is a lot of body parts groped
according to
the report the direct contact with
intimate body parts including the
touching of executive assistant number
one's breast
the grabbing and touching of the butts
of various women including executive
assistant number one and state entity
employee number one
and the governor's touching of trooper
number one's stomach and back
unquestionably amounted to sexual
harassment
in fact the law provides that direct
contact with an intimate body part
constitutes
one of the most severe forms of sexual
harassment the governor denies her
states he does not recall any of these
allegations of physical contact
but we find that the credible evidence
establishes that the governor in fact
touched these complainants in the way
they have described
those incidents amount to conduct that
clearly constitutes sexual harassment
these are the findings of attorney
general leticia james elected democrat
second the governor's numerous comments
of a sexually suggestive nature
including discussions about age
differences in partners at the same time
as the governor asked about finding a
girlfriend
miss bennett and trooper number one the
criteria for the girlfriend being
someone who can
handle pain trooper number one and
experiences with and views about
monogamy
whether an employee had been with an
older man feeling lonely and wanting to
be touched
the attractiveness of the employee and
comparing her to an ex-girlfriend
wanting to go out with two assistants
and calling them mingle mamas
whether an aide would be willing to
cheat on her partner playing strip poker
putting a tattoo on the butt as opposed
to the shoulder and locations of
piercings other than the ears
individually and collectively constitute
unlawful sexual harassment
this according to letitia james again
democrat we find these comments
some of which the governor denied other
of which he claimed were merely
misrepresented
to be by any reasonable measure
gender-based offensive and harassing
the law provides the comments such as
these need not have been overtly sexual
or motivated by sexual desire okay first
of all it is important to point out here
that sexual harassment law is super
duper vague particularly in states like
california and new york
so making a joke at the office can
easily be construed as sexual harassment
however it seems that uh
andrew cuomo had the unfortunate pension
for um
for saying all these sexually suggestive
things to aids and randoms
that he met like over and over and over
again
the law is clear these types of sexually
suggestive comments
if made as a joke or otherwise
particularly when part of a pattern of
comments in conduct as it was with the
governor
constitute unlawful sexual harassment
the complainant's not surprisingly said
that these types of suggestive comments
made them feel uncomfortable humiliated
unsettled
taken advantage of uncomfortable and
creeped out for the recipients of these
inappropriate comments and jokes from
the governor we find the governor indeed
created a hostile work environment uh
wait there's more
third we find that under the totality of
the circumstances
even the governor's less overtly sexual
comments that were nonetheless
gender-based
also created a hostile work environment
although the governor and certain of his
senior staff sought to downplay what the
evidence has revealed as frequent
gender-based comments and conduct by the
governor as simply old-fashioned or
cultural
neither explains nor justifies his
behavior nor makes it not harassing
for example referring to female staff as
honey sweetheart and darling
kissing staff members on the forehead
and some of the senior staff on the lips
holding them tightly around the waist
for pictures in other occasions allowing
senior staff members to sit
on his lap at official functions and
lying down with his head on the laugh of
staff members who are women we find
based on our interviews with numerous
executive chamber employees
did in fact create a hostile work
environment for many staff who were
women okay yeah
the last ones i'm gonna go with yeah
that's weird okay like if you got a guy
who's 60
and he says to women honey or sweetheart
i i don't think that that's like the end
of the world i know too many 65 year old
guys
who address everyone that way and also
address like pretty much anyone who's of
a younger generation that way because
they've been used to calling their kids
that that doesn't sound like andrew
cuomo here
and andrew cuomo i think it's a fairly
good bet that when you take your head
and put it in the lap
of a female employee that what
in the but so
yeah yeah that's not good as a matter of
law
claiming that the gender-based behavior
is simply a function of being
old-fashioned or culturally more
affectionate
is not a defense to sexual harassment
one of his employees named
miss lisz experienced the work
environment saying for whatever reason
in his office the rules were different
it was just you should view it as a
compliment if the governor finds you
aesthetically pleasing enough so even
though it was strange and uncomfortable
and technically not permissible in a
typical workplace environment
i was in this mindset that it was the
twilight zone and the typical rules did
not apply
what these witnesses and many others
described as not just old-fashioned
affectionate behavior
it was sexual harassment says the
laticia james report
apparently they also found that the
executive chamber failed to report and
investigate allegations of sexual
harassment that violated
their own internal policies according to
the report
like people made reports these were not
investigated or followed up
upon so that is a serious problem here
is the thing though
so latisha james says i don't know about
the whole like prosecution of this thing
i mean you know not really by the way
they also found unlawful retaliation
right that this report concludes that
the executive chamber meaning cuomo
engaged in prohibited retaliation
against lindsey boylan
in response to the allegation she made
on december 13th 2020 that the governor
had sexually harassed her
a lawful retaliation occurs when the
employer takes an adverse action against
an employee or former
employee because that person made a good
faith complaint formal or informal of
unlawful discrimination or harassment we
find this occurred with respect to
lindsey boylan
as detailed above the incidents boiling
described in her medium article and her
testimony have been
admitted and corroborated as well so he
engaged in a cover-up
and the original activity he engaged in
an
unwillingness to even investigate so the
governor's office did not investigate
however according to letitia james they
are uh
they have no real feelings on whether a
prosecution should
take place which uh is is a real cop out
here by letitia james obviously like the
fact that she
is is not pushing forward with any sort
of
criminal prosecution is fairly
incredible
but that is where things stand so now
the question is does he live this down
does he live this down and the answer is
probably
because if there's one thing that we
have learned at this point it's if you
don't leave no one can make you
first i want you to know directly from
me
that i never touched anyone
inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
i am 63 years old i've lived my
entire adult life in public view
that is just not who i am
and that's not who i have ever been so
are democrats in the state legislature
actually going to throw him overboard
are they actually going to toss him i
have serious doubts
i don't think so i think he's going to
stick around and then he's going to hope
that
people forget about this because they
did the first time right these
allegations have been out there for a
very long time
everybody has known that andrew cuomo
engages in this sort of behavior for
years
on end apparently if you just wait
long enough it goes away there is
another complaint i want to address
from a woman in my office who said that
i groped her in my home office
let me be clear that never happened
she wants anonymity and i respect that
so i am limited but what i can say
but her lawyer has suggested that she
will file a legal claim for damages
that will be decided in a court of law
trial by newspaper or biased reviews
are not the way to find the facts in
this matter
and and i will say i'm astonished i i
continue to be astonished
that cnn maintains ties with chris cuomo
okay there is a there is a report
appendix it includes
charlotte bennett's text about her
interactions with andrew cuomo and
an email from chris cuomo appearing to
draft a statement on behalf of his
brother so apparently chris
helped his brother draft a statement
responding to the allegations quote
questions have been raised about some of
my past interactions with people in the
office
i spent most of my time at work and
colleagues are often personal friends i
never intended to offend anyone or cause
any harm
sometimes i'm playful and make jokes
you've seen me do it at briefings
hundreds of times
my only desire is to add some levity and
banter to what is a very serious
business
i now understand my interactions may
have been insensitive or too personal
and some of my comments given my
position made others feel in ways i
never intended i'm sorry and feel deeply
embarrassed about that separately
my office has heard anecdotally some
people have reached out to ms bennett to
express his pleasure
about her coming forward my message to
anyone doing this is you have misjudged
what matters to me in my administration
you should stop now period this is a
statement apparently drafted
by chris cuomo on behalf of his brother
who at the exact time was um
the the the was covering his brother
uncovered
you'll recall in the middle of this
right it's it's
pretty amazing stuff so cnn has
like zero credibility at this point
frankly when it comes to covering these
sorts of issues
it is a shame for the cnn reporters who
don't suck but the fact that chris cuomo
gets to go out there and pretend to be a
moral better for everybody
uh continues to be futile to say the
very least
so that is where things stand i think
that he probably outlives this
because that is the rule in american
politics these days it is that you
basically it's not that you live that
you die as a hero or live long enough to
become the villain it's that you
die as a hero live long enough to become
the villain
or live even longer and then become the
hero again
which i think will eventually happen
with andrew cuomo i wouldn't be
surprised if andrew cuomo pushes
statewide lockdowns as a result of this
it's wag the coveted mask i would not be
surprised
at all if new york kicks into high gear
with regard to covet
just so we can go back to andrew cuomo
giving briefings about how necessary he
is
that would not be a giant surprise in
any way shape or form
okay so before we part today i have a
quick
olympic update the olympic update is
that gwen berry
remember her she was the hammer thrower
who turned away from the us flag
sadly she has failed to meddle at the
olympics which only demonstrates once
and for all that hammers are racist
according to the new york post gwenberry
failed to meddle during the women's
hammer throw finals on tuesday barry
finished in 11th place out of 12
competitors registering a distance of
71.35 meters
so she did not win that that is sad she
said that if she
had won she would have represented the
oppressed people
had she won a medal in tokyo saying
that's been my message for the last
three years well she has been denied
that possibility and america weeps
for her it is it is the saddest story of
the day
obviously also worth noting
i'm just gonna have to play this clip
because this clip is really astonishing
and i feel that it deserves
some level of independent comment so all
of the racial conversations that we have
been having
in the united states over the past year
or so
at the head of those racial
conversations is a woman in robin
deangelo you'll recall her as the author
of white fragility
i did an entire like 45 minute breakdown
of that awful awful book one of the
worst books ever written
on youtube you can go find it it's
pretty it's pretty funny okay so robin
deangelo
i think that she speaks for so many on
the left when she talks about
her embarrassment at her own race this
is this is how bad things have gotten in
the united states if people are
listening to robin d'angelo for racial
advice
and this just deserves comments here is
robin d'angelo yesterday
talking about her discovery of her own
white privilege
talk to me about when you first realized
you were white and
whiteness yeah talk to me about that um
i i it was a very abstract sense
i i honestly believe i was about um 34
years old
i was college educated i was a parent
um and someone handed me peggy
mcintosh's article
yeah and i read through that list
and i had an out-of-body experience i
could tell you where it was sitting
i i i'm not ever going to forget that
moment where
all of a sudden i was like oh my god i'm
white
right and i felt so loudly white that i
remember
being hesitant to go outside i didn't
want to go outside
because everybody could see that i was
white pagan
cult pagan cult i i
wow my skin color makes me bad and i was
hesitant to walk outside and
the sort of ritual performative nature
of this interview that she's doing
with a black interviewer is really
amazing but i guess this is what we have
become a society of ritual performances
it's a society of religious ritual
performances
in which we are asked to pay fealty to
our
public health authorities and to our
racial authorities to come into conflict
we got a bit of a problem as they're
about to in new york city but put that
aside
man there is a sickness in the head of
the united states public at this point
uh and uh it may be fatal all right
we'll back you later today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
coming up soon as the matt wall showed
us at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check
it out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show
morning wire on today's episode new
york's attorney general finds that
governor cuomo
sexually harassed multiple women new
york city issues a city-wide
proof-of-vaccination mandate and
whistleblowers expose more
troubling developments at the border
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire